[Applause]
[Music]
of DeAndre Hopkins and I'm Tara Lawrence
we're here in thermal California at the
BMW Performance Centre to test out the
all-new BMW 3-series I got you
alright gentleman we're here at the time
to autocross we're gonna put you guys on
the clock see who can get the fastest
time the rules are simple if any portion
of your car is outside of the designated
stop bomb a way at the box that's two
seconds added to your time are taking a
beat by oh man if you get a cone it's
for two seconds of penalty added to your
time for every tone that you hit if you
guys are ready let's get in the cars
let's do it I'm ready he's ready baby
[Music]
you know usually gonna light race and
senior citizen you know know you guys
Mahalo fine speeches to give this right
here has nothing to do with football
[Music]
became progressively down to the inside
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my trophy is haha feel good man feel
good my appreciation explosion sir you
know I got it right here
only three tents between coming in with
a 29 796 is DeAndre all right
then coming in was a 29 463 t oh hey
boom first place right there I take it
put it right up there with all the
others
now take huh good job what a
second-place prize I tell you what you
guys want to take a hot lap around the
track with me see how I do it yes do it
I will say T Oh view the winner so you
got the front seat the back seats were
all the motion is Oh DeAndre y'all
cheated minutes cuz I'm younger that's
all
[Music]